Boom and we're live.
How are you brother?
What's going on?
I'm cold.
It's good to see you.
Well,
this sucker up to you.
Boom.
I'm so good.
I'm very excited about your fight man.
Very excited.
Not as excited as I am.
Not to be.
I'm sure.
What,
how often does it that two undefeated,
I mean you're not heavyweight champion
cause they stripped you but you never
lost to undefeated heavyweight champions.
Go at it like this.
This is a huge fight.
Very much so.
It's never ever happened before ever.
It's pretty exciting.
Someone to as big as us.
Um,
I've never ever fought each other.
What do you think of it mean for people
who don't know you're fighting Deontay
wilder who's a,
an American undefeated knockout artists
and you are probably one of the more
interesting guys in the
heavyweight division.
Not just cause your personality,
but your skill set,
the way you move your long and tall.
But you've got great
footwork and your fast,
you know,
it's a very,
very interesting fight.
As far as like boxing technique.
It's power,
raw power versus boxing skill.
Two guys.
One six foot nine,
one six foot seven.
Both charismatic,
both talkers,
one British,
one American.
It doesn't get any
bigger than necessities.
The biggest flight that could be made of
this time in heavyweight division or in
the world of boxing
when you watched Deontay
wilder move around,
there's nobody that moves like that guy.
So odd.
Like it reminds me of Bambi on ice.
He doesn't really find his
legs underneath him now.
Sometimes he throws and he's
got no legs underneath them.
These just,
he's swinging and literally he's flying
through the air as he's punching.
I've seen him fall over
a few times as well.
Yeah.
Listen,
the guy tries to lung that big punch and
when you're trying to knock people out
with every single punch,
then if you miss it becomes a problem
when you go off balance and maybe follow
up.
Yeah.
Will you uh,
impressed with him and Louis Ortiz?
Fine.
I was impressed with him
because he came back,
he was losing all around.
I only gave wilder the round,
slightly knocked,
taught he's down in.
Um,
so he done well.
It was his acid test,
so to say,
come through all teases 49 years old.
I'm all beat,
at least.
Albie was pasties past his prime age,
but still undefeated champion coming in.
So it was a great victory
for Deontae world.
And he proved to me
that he can get combat,
get her to come back and win if I
yeah.
An rts comes from that Cuban system.
He's got great skills.
I mean,
yeah.
And he's looked fantastic and every single
fight other than that fight up until
that moment that he got hit.
Yeah.
Look,
you can't go swim in
and not get wet or teas.
I don't have a 300 amateur fights,
20 odd professional fights,
nearly knocked Tamale Mall.
I bought,
if I may be critical of
Louis Ortiz at us minute,
he stood in front of Deontay,
Walder right and punching range,
which is not a wise decision
considering the guys at 39 chaos.
He's movement.
He was trying to move a little bit,
but he was on old legs.
And I know a story.
What happened before that fight?
Louis Ortiz had very bad blood pressure.
Um,
doctor was gonna pull him out and
he had Charles Martin on standby,
but he said,
no,
I need the money.
So we went in a fort anyway and
he still nearly beat wilder.
Yes.
High blood pressure.
That's interesting.
And where and where are
you hearing this from?
Good sources.
Good source.
Yeah,
those are the best source is
always the best inside info.
You're an interesting story man,
because not just because your personality,
but because you're,
you've come back from
mental illness and you very,
very open about it.
Yeah,
no,
I think that's,
that's a very unique thing where I'm,
I remember when you,
when you beat Klitschko and won the
title and then you kind of went off the
rails and I thought
you were just partying.
You know,
when,
when I heard about it I thought wow,
God,
I made a shit load of money,
became the heavyweight champion.
All the pressure and the
press and all the craziness.
But it was more than that.
It was more than that.
It started off like I'll suffered with
mental health problems my whole life,
but I didn't know what it was.
Cause I never had no
education on the mater.
Uh,
money wasn't til after the Klitschko fi
I'm very massive hockey than I ought to
have.
A even worse I low,
lowest low that anyone could ever have.
Um,
I'd wake up and I think,
why did I wake up this morning?
This is coming from my money.
You want everything,
money,
fame,
glory,
titles,
our wife,
our family,
kids,
everything.
But I felt as if I had nothing.
I felt there was an empty gaping hole
that was just filled with gloom and doom.
And I just was,
one bad thing happened
to me after another,
within seven days,
the IBF strip me of that title because
I couldn't defend against gloves.
Golf.
He was a nobody because allery much closer
volodymyr but the IBF wasn't expected
me to beat Vladimir.
So they took that clause in air anyway,
thinking bloody me is going to announce
to defend against class coffee because I
won.
They,
they stripped me of the belt,
which none of my reason
within seven days of the fight.
Yeah,
that's insane.
How can they require you to fight
within seven days?
They didn't vote.
They required me to go into negotiations.
So just not going into negotiations to
sign these strip you within seven days.
Yeah.
Well they knew I couldn't go into
negotiations because already much close
boxing's a dirty bus.
So I was stuck in between
a rock and a hard place.
Yeah.
And that's what happened.
That was one belt.
God,
I'll learn my team and the coach coach
team or carrying on about where the
flight was going to be.
It was going to be on
a cruise ship in Dubai.
It was going to be here.
It was going to be there.
Time was dragging on a cruise ship.
A cruise ship.
Yeah.
There was some Arab billionaire who wanted
to make this fight in exclusive fight
for him and his buddies.
No.
Yeah,
come on.
Seriously.
This fight was heading for a cruise ship.
That fucking oil money,
man,
they got some money and
if they can afford it,
do it.
That's what I say.
That would have been the most hilarious
scenario ever for a world heavyweight
title fight a bunch of Arab
billionaires on a cruise ship.
Wow.
So the strip you of the IBF belt,
you go into negotiation with
Klitschko for the rematch.
How in the rematch never happened.
Very much.
Didn't happen initially because I
went over on my uncle in training.
Um,
I was in Holland training folder.
He much on,
I was running up on the heavy terrain and
I went over from ankle sprain my ankle
quite badly.
So we had to postpone the folly.
But,
but that time I was off like say three
months getting his uncle right and all
up.
I just,
I just didn't want to do any,
if you know what I mean.
I didn't have the desire.
The fire wasn't burning no longer to
fight and I was suffering with depression
the whole time.
Even in training camp,
before I sprained my ankle,
I was depressed as depressed,
could be on a daily basis.
I don't think,
why am I feeling like this?
I don't have no reason to fail like it.
Some people will say,
oh well each attention
seeking or whatever,
but unless you've
experienced what I'm saying,
it's still of impossible to understand
where it had been aware of come from.
And it just went from bad to worse.
Um,
I hate the drink heavily on a daily basis.
I hit the drugs.
Um,
I was out all night party team of
women of the night and not coming home.
And you know,
I didn't care about boxing.
I didn't care about living it,
just wanting to die and I was going to
have a good time doing it while I was
doing it.
I used to drink and take drugs to get
away from their depression because when I
was drunk or high,
then I wouldn't,
uh,
I wouldn't think about being depressed
for fall about being a boxing champion or
I'm,
I feel great.
But as we know when the drink was off,
he only leaves you with a bad hangover
and failing even more depressed.
But someone who suffers
with mental health,
the worst thing we can do to
escape it is take drugs or alcohol.
But yeah,
that's the most common approach.
And that's the common approach because
people we don't know cause it's not spoke
about.
And this is why I want to spread
the word on mental health.
So when other people are in
this position in the future,
they know where to go and they know
what to do because there's a blueprint.
Well,
Kudos to you for doing that because so
so few people have the courage to talk
about their struggles when they go
through that because it seems like a
weakness.
Yeah.
You know,
it's,
it's very powerful that you were willing
to do that and just be open and honest
about it.
There's a few people out
there that are doing that now.
You know,
our friend moral Rinaldo,
he's gone through some some serious
mental health issues and he's very open
about it and talks about
it quite a bit now.
When you were training for the first
Klitschko fight for the fight rather,
did you have it then?
Not really,
no.
I was set focused on what I wanted to
do and that was beat Vladimir Klitschko.
I believe when you've got a goal in mind
or from being a child all your life and
you do that,
then I was like obviously lost.
I was almost like I didn't have
anything more to do in my life,
although I could a carried on on,
defended the belt,
some whatever.
I wasn't really interested in
doing that I'd beat them on.
I'd always wanted to do because
when I was an amateur boxer,
I used to watch flood in mayor Klitschko
on TV as a world heavyweight champion.
And I always aimed,
he was my target to beat.
I want to finally beat him.
It was like climbing Mount Everest and
didn't have anything more to prove.
And the fire was debt.
There was no fire.
I was forcing myself to fight and I always
said I didn't want to be one of those
people who just fought for money because
there's plenty of people were money in
the world,
plenty of them.
But who knows him?
Um,
the reasons for me fight in,
it's not for money or,
or for belts or glory,
a fight because I don't
know anything else.
I've always been a fighter from
being born to being 30 years old.
Now it's all I love to do.
I don't have any of a passion.
I've locked.
The Lord knows I've locked and if I had
anything else that was going to our I
could do,
I'd be doing it.
I just,
I tried retirement.
I was 27 I retired on in the second man
in boxing heavyweight history to retire
on beaten as a world champion
like rocky Malsiano before me,
but it wasn't enough.
I was like,
I am lost without this fight game.
I tried golfing,
I tried clay pigeon shooting.
I tried four by four in,
I tried going to strip clubs,
bars,
restaurants,
everything,
and it was just like I had this emptiness
inside where I just want it to fight.
Well,
in comparison to what you've accomplished,
everything else has to seem pretty dull.
I mean,
until you step into the ring
with Vladimir Klitschko,
who was widely considered to be one
of the greatest heavyweights ever,
and you box his face off.
I mean that was a beautiful performance.
It walls shut him down.
It was weird.
It was weird to watch them.
It's like there was moments
in that fight where he just,
he just looked like he didn't
know what to do with you.
I'm going to see you again on December.
The first,
like I said,
to flood has had to,
same thing to Deontay wilder.
You fought the Americans,
you fought the Mexican,
you fought a Europeans.
Paul,
you ain't never fought
the gypsy king before.
I said it straight Tivola in me.
I said,
you look in our king.
eve,
you've ever for king before?
He said,
no.
I said,
we fight him on now.
And he said,
you're going to lose to one.
Well,
he's lost before,
but he's lost because he got
clipped and hurt and stopped.
And I was very impressed with him actually
in the Anthony Joshua fight because
he came back from getting badly
hurt and almost put Joshua away.
But the fight with you is different
because you just outboxed him.
And he was known as the
guy who would box and hold,
Jab,
and hold.
I mean,
he was one of the most boring
heavyweights of all time.
Fantastically successful.
But from a spectator point of view,
you watched some of his
fights and like Jesus Christ,
he would jab you,
grab you,
Jab and grab you.
I mean,
that was his thing.
Right hand grabbed you.
It worked here.
25 title defenses.
I mean it was very successful,
but that shit didn't work with you.
It didn't for the first time in his
whole career he was fighting somebody who
was not just bigger than him,
but more off LATIC who could move more.
Yeah,
so money wasn't just
looking for one lucky punch.
I knew going into the fight
in me a flight that everybody,
all the rest of the opponents
and 25 men before me,
I'd all went in trying
to do the same thing,
try to knock him out and he's got,
he's got so men of a,
a weird defense where he puts both arms
out in front of him and it's almost very
awkward to London,
not chain where big punches so far.
I'm not going to do that.
Not gonna make that mistake.
I'm going to outbox him on all me
teams that there's not a good idea.
We've got to go to Germany to try now.
Box a super champion and
try and win on the cards.
Are you crazy?
I said,
yes.
but if I wasn't crazy,
I won't be great.
And I went over there and
outboxed him and nobody,
nobody apart from my
brother or me father fought,
I could do it.
You know,
even people who were close to me and camp,
they were like,
they were very unsure of
what was gonna happen.
I may be me.
I always had a little smile on
my face because I believed it.
I believed I could always beat flooding.
Miracle it go.
I even told Vladimir years before,
when I was 22 I said,
I will beat you one day in
manual steward told him to God,
rest his soul.
He said,
Tyson fury is the heir to the throne.
and when his time is ready
will be you straight to him.
Pardon me?
I hated that he hated him and
y'all talking about me like that.
We don't have evil.
Why?
Well,
let me sure.
It was good fire under him
during training as well.
Now you,
you were focused for that fight.
You were,
you were prepared and afterwards,
was it just the realization that you
would accomplish this incredible goal?
It's set into depression.
Was it you didn't know what to do next
or was it just that your focus was now no
longer on this unattainable,
you know,
like almost insurmountable obstacle in
front of you becoming the heavyweight
champion of the world.
All of a sudden you did it.
Then the depression kicks in.
Yeah,
my conditioning train a Christian,
he said to me before the Klitschko Fai,
he said,
what will you do after you win?
I said,
probably be depressed for a long time.
He said,
why?
I said,
truthfully,
I was almost expecting it and I
didn't think I'd have a box again.
Even the day after the Klitschko fight,
sky's boss interviewed me that the UK
broad customer put it on and they said,
what's next for Tyson theory?
I said,
I'll probably never box again.
I knew.
I said to me,
dad and my brothers before the fight,
a week before the fight,
I said,
win,
lose or draw.
I said,
this is probably going to be my last
fight cause I knew the fire was going.
I didn't have that hunger anymore.
Had the hunger to beat Vladimir Klitschko
bought not to carry on and continue.
And I said I didn't want it to
be about money or financial gain.
I want it to be the best of my time,
beat the best month.
And that's what I did.
And I was a me where worded,
I didn't box again until
two and a half year later I decided to
make a comeback because I was sitting
here 400 pounds,
drug addict and Alcoholic,
by the way,
had never took a drug in my life until
I got to 27 really never smoked weed.
Not,
not morphing.
And what drove with drugs?
What were the drugs of choice
once you won the title?
Cocaine was the usual one and that was it.
Really.
Cocaine and alcohol.
It's like rollercoaster,
crazy drug,
drug and alcohol.
But you know,
I look back on it now and I think
what I changed that I wouldn't,
I'm not many people will think,
well this man's crazy for
saying that on a radio show.
But I wouldn't change a thing because
I know it was supposed to happen and I
needed to be tested to see
what type of character of us.
Although I did all those mud things and
I went for wall that time and I tried to
commit suicide and I,
how'd you try to commit suicide?
Well,
I'll tell you what happened.
I,
like I said,
I was waking up on,
I didn't want to be alive.
I was making everybody's life a misery.
Everybody was close to
me and was pushing away.
Nobody could talk to me,
talk any sense into me at all.
And
I'd go very,
very,
very low at times a very low and I start
thinking all these crazy thoughts and
this start near the,
and I was in me car.
I bought a,
bought a brand new Ferrari convertible
in the summer of 2016 and I was in the,
Alan was on the highway on this,
a strip of highway where I am,
I'm at the bottom of
about a five mile strip.
There's a massive bridged across as a
motorway and I knew that and I got the car
up to 190 miles an hour.
I was heading towards up
bridge and I didn't care or no,
almost sinking.
I didn't care about her,
to me family,
me,
my career,
people who friends,
anybody.
I didn't care.
I didn't care about nothing.
I just want to die so bad.
I give up on life and just as it was
getting towards upper edge or one 19 and
his Ferrari,
it a crushed like a coke come
by the way I've heard of it.
I heard a voice say,
no,
don't do this.
Tyson,
think about your kids.
Think about your family and you'll all
boys and girls growing up with no father
and everyone saying
your dad was a week mum.
He left his,
he took the easy way out because
he couldn't do anything about it
before are turned into the bridge.
I,
uh,
pulled on the motor and I was shaking.
I could feel myself shaking and I pulled
over and I was all nervous and didn't
know what to do.
And I was frightened and I was so afraid
and a fall that day,
I'll never,
ever,
ever try or think about
taking me on life ever again.
And I didn't.
I went and got help from
a delete in psychiatrist,
um,
doctor in the UK and my
dad were not with me.
And she said to me that she said,
can I have a word alone with you,
John?
He said,
Yah.
I mean,
I've told me what she
said when he came out.
She said,
hey,
it's not to be trusted alone.
He's an imminent death risk.
That's the highest level of suicide
risk that she'd ever assessed it.
And she said,
without his faith,
he would have been dead a long time ago.
But she said,
faith alone ain't gonna hold
him cause that's going to break.
I'm on site goes,
he's done.
So I'll pop my dad's life terror as well
because he was checking up on me all
the time.
He wanted to be with me 24 seven he was
even asleep and in my house with me,
married man before kids,
I was in a right state.
I'll just,
I just,
I want it.
I just didn't want to live anymore and
I had everything that man could want.
There wasn't nothing I didn't have,
but it meant nothing.
Nothing meant.
And even I thought worthless on.
The longer it went on,
the more it,
it hurt inside in the
Moros ERT and everybody,
everybody give up on me.
And before farm we fall,
I was definitely gonna die and
I was going to kill myself.
And after that I tried.
I was thinking to myself,
you know what?
I need to get better.
I need to,
I need to do something.
But every time I tried to go to the gym,
I don't know if voice say,
Nah,
this ain't for orals anymore.
I'm not going to do this.
I didn't want to do it.
I'd run.
I'd run 200 yards and pull up.
I wouldn't even get a mile.
I think.
Ugh.
Can't be bothered.
I don't want to do this.
Boxing is not for me.
I hated boxing at one stage in 2016 early
17 I wouldn't have done a boxing fight
for this room full of diamonds.
No Way.
I hated box in,
I won't watch on the TV.
I won't read about it.
I hated boxing.
I've done it my whole life and I
didn't want no part of it anymore.
Um,
I was out drinking.
I didn't gag,
give up taking drugs like I said.
And it comes to a point or
was doing that for 18 months.
My life.
And I was out 2017 Halloween.
I was a 400 lbs,
dressed up as a skeleton and I go
to this fancy dress party in it.
I'm looking around and I'm thinking,
these are all young kids compared to me.
I'm 30 and I feel like I was the
oldest guy in there like 29 I was like,
what am I doing here?
Is this what you want for your life?
And I thought to myself,
this is not me a number.
How many people told me before this
while I was going wrong,
what was due and you
need to act to your life.
You can only change your life
if you want to change it.
And I left and everyone said,
are you going?
Oh,
early said,
yeah.
I left at nine o'clock.
I went home and I got back home.
I didn't say anything to the line,
but it went straight
upstairs into a dark room
and I took burst.
Chief had skeleton,
so tough.
I know I was up there and I got on my
knees and I was praying and begging God to
help me.
I don't know,
at this point I'd never,
I've never begged or cried
to God to help maybe for her,
prayed a lot,
all my life,
but I'd never been in this
physical state before.
I could feel tears running down my face.
My chest was wet with tears because
I knew I couldn't do it on my own.
It wasn't possible for me because I tried
and tried and tried and ended up back
in Nepal,
back drinking.
I almost accepted that that was
going to be my fate and alcoholic.
So I was on my knees in his bedroom.
Um,
after praying for about 10 minutes,
I got up and I felt the weight of the
world was lifted off my shoulders and for
the first time in years I knew
it was going to make a comeback.
And I called,
my wife has said Paris,
Paris,
she a ball.
She was drunk coming home from the pope.
I said,
Monday morning I start to regain
mission to try and get the heavyweight
championship of the world buck.
She said,
yeah,
yeah.
Because before this,
every time I'd have a beer,
I'd come back and I'm going to be the
heavyweight champion of the world again.
Cause it was,
it was the alcohol talking.
So I was like the man who called
Wolf a thousand times on this,
this jeep had Korea that I,
that I was living on the past thinking
about years before glory days.
And after this prior I got up,
I said,
boy,
this is going to be,
she didn't believe me one second.
But even when I speak to her now,
she says,
not night.
You told me that.
She said,
I earn a difference in your voice
swimming up and next day I phoned up Ben
Davison and I said,
I don't want to go back downhill
route but as same trainer,
same promote to say many
things and everything's got
to change as it's is going
to be a new Tyson fury.
And we called it,
returned to the mock mission.
And as I went out that morning off the
phone in Bannon or arranging everything
and went out for a run,
it may sweat soaked out IOD
ambitions of running two miles.
I got about five minutes into the Roman,
stopped on a walked
and while I was walking,
I can't run them too up to 400
pounds before I'm going to walk,
I'm going to get out and walk.
While I was walking,
I was flicking through my phone on
Instagram and I sees this video of
[inaudible] tape,
wilder say in,
Yep.
Tyson theories finally done that because
the week before I'd been a boxing show
in Manchester or something
and the press took a picture.
I mean,
it was like everywhere.
This big fat out of shape,
ugly ball that it bearded
white as a sheet man.
I was like a state and a this video.
Yet after seeing this
evidence at Tyson fury,
I finally know he's finished.
It can never come back.
And if he,
even if our water fought
him and he's aid aid,
I'd have knocked him out.
And before that he was
talking about Mike Tyson.
Now we'd not Mike Tyson.
I went around and I thought myself,
that was very disrespectful to talk about
someone who's not even from your era
and one and divide them
and all that sort of stuff.
What?
There's no possible chance.
So photos have,
you know what I've ever do,
fight you.
I'm going to give it you for that reason.
And then when I saw this over video of
him saying things about me and that I
couldn't come back,
he gave me that much more motivation
to return just so I can beat Deontay
wilder.
So I'd always caught cases on as well.
I was being charged where we've
taken performance and unseen drugs.
Nandrolone something I'd never done.
I had,
I had an nandrolone enemies system.
It's produced naturally,
nobody,
but they say my levels were elevated.
Dka,
UK Anti doping said there
was no case to answer,
but all of a sudden I had a big water
case on me that took three years to salt
out and buy on every one side.
Y'All getting in Hotmail,
Donnie Hassan,
you get a 12 year bomb and I said,
you know what?
Well you've 12 years,
not just for an Angelo.
I'm refused on as well.
I was in a bad mood one day and the
drug test and people come in the gym and
I've told them to fuck off.
This is when you were
training for your comeback?
This was when I was out with training.
Yeah.
When I was just all the time I was fat
and out of shape and not train and I was
still being run them
drug tested by UK Aad.
Really?
That's why I tested
positive twice for cocaine
and everyone said no,
he never getting back the,
the boxing board of control spending
my license in the UK for the cocaine,
um,
use.
So I had a court case looking
at been far band forever,
basically suspension.
The doctor made me
medically unfit to fight,
so that was after I forgot about that bit.
When I was rescheduling
the Klitschko to fight,
the psychiatrist phoned up and he says,
look,
he is medically unfit.
He can't fight anybody,
don't want to live,
nevermind fight.
So I was medically deemed unfit to box,
suspended by the boxing board of
Control for the cocaine use on out an
underlying case on me.
I'm a refusal case and by the way,
it was racking up millions of
dollars in lawyers' face too.
But I was so confident
that I was going to,
everything was going to be okay
because when I was down on my knees,
I just knew that it was going to
be okay and everyone was like,
what's the point in training and doing
anything with you when you're not,
you can't do anything.
You're not in a position to do it.
I said,
everything's going to be all right.
Don't worry.
Court case comes along in December,
we'll go.
They say,
right,
this court case has dragged
on insufficient evidence.
Get rid of it.
We both agreed that we was going
to call it quits on the case.
I like on my way.
They got,
as they pay their legal fees,
I pay my legal fees.
Tom,
that was a drugs case out the window.
Finished
the suspension.
I got to meet him with a border
control in the UK and they said,
look,
if if you can get past medically
fit by doctor mentally,
then we'll reassess your case.
I'm telling and denied.
So I said right,
no problem.
Phone doctor,
the psychiatrist or
seeing people who would,
who had spoke to all these doctors,
three or four different doctor,
Phil's,
Dr. Jones,
whoever else said or I need to,
I need reassessing.
Reyes has me bang pass with flying colors
and went back to the border control
handed in my certificate by
all these different doctors,
examinations,
physical and mental.
They said we have no other choice
but to give you a license reinstated,
Bang.
So it was three of the biggest
obstacles in my life at once.
We're all done within a
month or two straight away.
Then I just had the easy
task of lose in 160 pounds,
whichever kind of got overall,
I'm other things.
Losing weight as a fighter was
something that I'd done that tron.
Anyway,
so then me and Ben sat about losing
this 160 pounds along the way back home.
Spoke to Frank Warren.
He became a promoter.
I'm frank said,
right,
you've on a long time out the ring.
You've abused your body.
Let's get your four or five comeback
flights just so you're ready.
I said,
okay,
no problem.
Healthy might fight.
How'd the other combat fight?
I said to frank,
I don't need any more combat fights.
Make the wilder flight now.
No,
no,
no.
He said,
let's have a couple more just in case.
I said,
I'm telling you,
make the wild a fight.
So this is where people don't understand.
I've picked Deontay wilder.
He didn't pick me.
I picked him.
Well,
he needs a high profile
opponent right now,
but does it looks like,
I mean,
I don't want to say that
Joshua was ducking him,
but it looked like he had to say that.
Yeah,
there's something going on.
He Wa who,
whether it's as his
management or his promoter,
they didn't seem to want
that fight right away.
I know some quite close details on that.
Todd is the detail details is um,
wildest team offered Joshua's team,
$80 million for a two flight deal,
$50 million for the first fight.
And I'm 30 million for the rematch.
If Joshua lost and they declined
up and my lawyer Robert Davis,
he saw a proof of funds from my layman.
So Eddie earn and he's,
each chunk buddies can all
say this suddenly of a pull.
I know the truth cause
proof of funds we're seeing.
So you think it's because
of when Klitschko knocked
him down and had him hurt,
they were worried about
Deontae with his big power.
I don't think it's about eva fighter.
It's bigger than that.
It's about money,
about keeping the money role,
keeping the golden goose lane,
their mags,
looking after it.
Don't take any risks with Joshua was
Olympic gold medalist and in the UK it's a
massive story.
Sells out stadiums,
70,000,
90,000.
Huge Star.
Huge data.
Um,
so why would you want to get him beat
by somebody who nobody's really heard of
or even take a risk of it?
They took the risk in Nicolette JCO fight.
It almost didn't pay off.
They scrape through skin of the teeth,
put heat on it,
fair play.
He got up off the canvas,
showed a champion's heart to come back
and knock out Klitschko fairplay ball.
Since then,
they haven't remotely
stepped off a tall default.
Joseph Parker,
and he did knock Josee Park,
right?
It didn't even hurt Josie Parker,
he fought Carlos Tucker
had a hard fight with him,
had a hard fight,
hard fight.
So that just keeping up money,
train going.
And I don't blame him because this
is a business at the end of the day.
And if I was his management team,
I'd say stay away from fury.
Stay away from wilder and we'll just
fight the rest of the people and keep
making plenty of money.
Why do we need to fight these guys who
are very risky for that may be a little
bit more than we're getting now.
Two Times more,
right?
But in the long run,
we can have five plates and not get
beat by mediocre people who were,
no,
he's going to beat and get the same
money or more so it doesn't make sense.
So this is why me wild.
Everyone agreed to fight
because at one time or another,
it's got to be more than about money.
Like we're fighters were.
Wherever you were,
tell me is the world,
of course,
we've made money in our careers,
have a 28 professional fight,
27 professional flights.
I've made money.
It's about more than Molly now.
Surely if I spend the money have
already wasted and I'm stupid,
then 200 million would be no good
to me because I'd spend anyway,
right?
We Dot always has a felony.
He's mourning is very easily part of it.
But that's another story for another day.
Going back on to this fight,
we owe it to the funds to gave them a
proper fight of two so called people who
think that the best.
Let's prove it.
It wasn't a hard negotiation thing on
a steel Neeva when me and wild hope you
don't mind and hope he's team,
don't mind me saying that
they were the most terrorist,
more straight going people
I've ever worked with.
There was no if buts or maybes.
Wherever I asked for,
they agreed and I have it.
He asked for,
I've agreed to.
There was no,
it was no hard negotiations.
It was very,
very simple.
Wild,
clearly
seems to want to prove that he's the best.
Um,
I've got to admire him for that.
Myra,
that as well.
I mean,
he's got a title,
he's undefeated.
He's smashing everybody.
They put in front of them and
he has a legacy on his mind.
He wants to leave.
A real legacy is why
he looked to fight you.
Yeah.
I believe that I've got to give Deontay
wilder a lot of credit and respect for
an aberration because he seems to be that
he was the only man at the time before
I was even coming back.
He was willing to risk everything he's
got to prove is the best and isn't that
what flight is about?
Where men want to prove to
the best of all the others.
No,
he's absolutely behaving
like a true champion.
I mean,
that's what everybody,
that's what fans want.
They want a guy like
that and a guy like you,
I,
I've got admire him because to
pick me a six hot nine mover,
Ooh,
slick and fast and can do awkward things,
tussle,
awkward fight for him.
He could have picked
more cheesier opponents
on May similar money bolt.
He didn't,
he opted for the toughest one.
Oh,
still could test our respect him for
that and I take me out off to him.
Well,
I think this is going to be a giant fight.
I really do because this is what
everybody's been wanting for a long time.
It's so difficult to get people
excited about the heavyweight division.
I mean,
Joshua was a giant fan in the UK,
but worldwide,
not so much.
Not so much.
And Deontay wilder,
even though he's had
these spectacular results,
he needs that big thing too.
To put him over the top.
The Ortiz fight helped,
but he needs something more to,
to capture the real,
the,
the love of the American public,
the love of the world.
He just hasn't quite grabbed it yet.
[inaudible] on.
I do feel sorry for him in a way,
because he has had for two professional
fights and knocked out nearly
everybody's calls.
He should be a huge superstar.
Shouldn't be,
but he's not.
I go down the street,
whatever.
I am,
New York,
Los Angeles,
big bear.
And if I have 50 people
whose Deontay wilder,
maybe one might even recognize the name.
And someone even said,
I recognize the name.
Is he a ballplayer?
Is he a hockey player?
I said,
no,
he's heavyweight champion of the world.
It's crazy because he's a flashy dresser.
He's a great talker.
He knocks people and do
another fucking dimension.
He's a wild guy to watch fight.
He's very exciting.
It's just,
he's got all the,
Eh,
he's just waiting for the big moment.
And maybe this fight is the
big moment for one of you.
It is.
Um,
they think it's so much to do with the
heavyweight division's been in Europe for
the last 15 years and been put to sleep.
I believe that too.
The thing about Klitschko
is even though he was very,
very successful and his style was
amazing in terms of his success rate,
God damn,
those fights were born to watch.
Nobody gave a shit about those fights.
No.
Outside Europe,
Germany,
global phenomenon.
Well,
they were just happy lived in Germany,
was speaking German.
He ate,
sell out 50,000,
60,000 fight in and nobody,
I mean,
it was a,
a wonderful investment for him.
I mean,
no disrespect to him.
He's a great boxer for sure.
But
boxing is,
it's entertainment as well as sport,
especially for the casual person.
You know,
I mean,
I,
if I watch,
uh,
great boxer,
just,
you know,
box well and play it safe,
I can be very impressed with that.
But the average person is
not going to be impressed.
You're not going to get
some paper view dollars,
hundred percent of them.
I can't sit here and pretend to most,
some of my fights have been the most
exciting fights in the wild becomes my
biggest fight of my whole Korea
was a 12 round snooze fest.
I'm,
I don't have to say that.
Hi,
I'm amount of Avala and I
will tell you the truth.
I can't even watch a fight back.
It was all boring.
It didn't think it was Bob.
He was to box in people who know boxing
to know hard while I was doing is to do
as a heavyweight and
the scale and all that.
But like you say to the average Joe who
knows nothing about box and he wants to
see two big men punch the
shit out of each other.
It was a boring fight to,
that's why Joshua gets
more credit for each.
Went over Klitschko even though he got
popped down and really knocked out than I
did.
And Klitschko didn't love the glove on
me because their fight was 50 50 I knew
it was locking arms off each other,
but my fight was like 80 20 in my
favor where I didn't get torched.
But that still was spectacular.
He was watching it as a fight fan.
First of all,
it was no disrespect to Klitschko
but it was like finally,
finally somebody figured this dude out
because there had been moments where
people had,
you know,
tested him a little bit,
but it had been a long time
before somebody had beaten him.
It don't,
it had been there 11 years.
Yeah,
but that isn't always been my style.
Boxing on the back foot,
slip and slide,
I'm adjust to different
opponents loud to me,
I'd dynamite in his right hand regardless
of his boring style or whatever.
If he made a mistake once in
that fight you get knocked out.
Eddie Chambers,
so many Samuel Peters,
everybody list goes on
and on and on and on.
Everybody knocked out 65 knockouts and
he would make you desperate because of
that style cause that grab,
Jab and grab style.
People would get desperate and they
would open themselves up and then getting
out toe and I didn't want to be
on that list of knockouts bought.
I've been,
I've been in fights where he's been total
walls for as long as the fight lasted.
Aida,
Steve Calling on fight 2013 I'll come
out here or come from Iran or straight
onto an overrun,
right and down.
I was looking enough up Mallesons glad
God and roof the lights and the off 12
fuck me.
It's now back to the farm boy.
Get up.
What's Cunningham?
A difficult opponent because he
was shorter than you calling them.
Believe it or not in this
going to sound strange.
Calling him was the
hardest fight I ever did.
Have a whole Korea
amateur or professional.
The reason B and he was very slippery
the way I explained calling them.
It was like a Conga real all
full of oil in front of me.
I can pin him down.
He was light on his feet.
He was weighing 208 pounds
or something Peyser way,
right?
He was a,
he was a three time cruiserweight champ,
middle the world and he
stepped up into heavyweights.
He was a slick,
talented boxer and I,
I tried to walk him down,
use me size and power,
but he's just out box in me.
What?
I'm good at.
Boxing move in,
slipping and sliding.
I couldn't do against Dave
couldn't come because he was too,
he was quicker than me.
He was,
he was,
he was like,
it was a better boxer all around to me.
I couldn't do nothing with him and he'd
knocked me over and even though he was a
light punch her supposedly what?
Right onto it come from
the back of the hole.
They go over and write right
in the Chin and the fall,
this has hit us day B
have been knocked out.
I fought Tyson theory,
get up and kick his ass.
So I got up and I just went straight
forward our team and I thought no mailbox
and now I'm going to hit
him around in the body,
pull them up through the middle,
rounder corners.
You might be ahead on points but
sooner or later I'm going to get you.
And I did in round seven.
I felt him going week cause
I was just pushing him back,
pushing him back and he's hitting me
gloves and hitting me face and hit me
everywhere basically.
But I walked right through
everything when regard up.
Um,
after he got tired I am of a heavy
body shot and round seven and he didn't
recover an had pushed his head back and
knocked him clean out with the right
talent.
That was the only time he was
ever knocked out when his career,
even to today,
it seemed like in that fight,
perhaps one of the more difficult things
was adjusting to the fact that he was
so much smaller than you.
Six,
six 43 was,
yeah.
Yeah.
Didn't you were just took you
a while to adjust to that.
Like I say,
I'm not going to make any excuses.
Steve Conning and was a
better boxer at American.
Good fighter.
Yeah.
Small guy for the heavyweight division,
but a very good fighter.
Very good.
Like I said,
the toughest money ever
face was still calling them.
That's a high praise.
So when you decided that you were going
to make this comeback and you're dealing
with all this,
these mental health struggles,
what did you do to overcome
the mental health problems?
What did you do to
overcome the depression?
Like I say,
when I got up off that floor and a weight
lifted off me and I had my mind set
for the first time in two years
till I wanted to do something again.
I think the way to beat mental
health has setting goals,
giving yourself short
term or long term goals.
And that's what I did.
That's very interesting.
I give myself a goal of losing the weight,
pound by pound.
Basically.
I'll set myself a 10 pound,
um,
target and I'd reached out and,
and I sent myself and have a 10 pound,
15 pound whatever,
and I'd give myself a
little rewards and stuff.
I wasn't obviously eating junk food.
I was on a strict diet for six months
and I was training twice a day,
six,
seven days a week.
But with the mental health,
I don't suffer with mental
health when I'm active one,
I've got a goal.
How do I think most people
will vouch for this?
If you suffer with mental health problems,
you tend to suffer on
when you're on your own,
when you've got a lot of time to
think and when you're not doing much.
But when you busy on a daily basis,
you don't have enough time
to think about mental health.
And I figured out,
well,
if I exhaust myself in the gym,
I come on,
I'm too tired to think about anything.
I just want to get some
food and go to bed.
So that's what I do.
So you didn't use medication?
I didn't use medication,
no.
Wow.
I will say I was prescribed
with medication from the doctor,
but I refuse to take it.
I took a couple of pills,
helped me software,
lax
from the doctor.
Bhat never took them again.
I only ever taco couple.
Would they give you,
I think it was like [inaudible]
pan try Ozzie panel,
something like that.
Some antidepressants,
some antidepressant pill.
Yeah.
But I've done research on them and
I didn't like what I was seeing.
Like on.
I knew my grandfather,
my dad's dad,
he was addicted to pills his whole life.
Pells that didn't even
do anything for him.
There was placebo pills,
but without him he
couldn't function really.
So I didn't want to become one of them
macaron dough to take pills and they
didn't do anything to him.
Put it in his own mind.
He fought,
they were doing something
calming him down and I didn't,
didn't want to be one of them people.
There was a point in my life
where I haven't done hard fought.
I was gonna end up in a padded room.
Lots of body was.
But it's fascinating that you're saying
that setting goals and setting your mind
on things and hard training
is what set you back on track.
You know,
I don't know what you're like when
there's no one in front of you,
but standing here in
front of you right now,
I would say this is a healthy,
vibrant guy.
100% I've never felt better,
mentally strong physically.
I've trained in hard fail,
fit as a fiddle.
You know,
I wouldn't be here if I
was anything wrong with me,
but as fascinating that most people think
that to come back from a mental health
issue like yours,
you need psychiatric care
and you need medication.
And your saying you did it with
setting goals and hard work.
And the biggest thing we're
missing here is I didn't,
I didn't do it.
We're doctors and um,
all of type of things,
I don't know.
It was something way more powerful.
God.
So your faith and your belief,
me,
faith and belief that God would
make me better made me better.
Almost like faith.
Any faith will think,
oh,
is this nonsense or whatever book.
I'm living proof.
Well if you believe in something and just
like you were talking about believing
in pills that don't do anything,
belief is a powerful thing.
Whether it,
who knows what's behind that belief.
But what you're saying is so powerful
that you just by virtue of changing the
way you think about things,
setting goals,
working hard,
you lifted yourself out of the worst
depression of your life to the point where
you were suicidal.
Hundred percent.
And I've never ever went back to that
from this data out and it's been been one
over 12 months.
That's pretty amazing.
I mean it's just amazing.
That's an amazing thing for people to
hear because there's a lot of people that
rely heavily on
antidepressants and medication.
They think that is the only way for
them to be happy and for them to be not
suicidal,
not depressed.
They need that medication.
And for them to hear what your saying
I think is a very powerful thing.
It is bull.
I'm no doctor.
I'm not going to tell people to
chuck away your pills and right,
but it doesn't do any arm.
What I'm saying?
Give it a whirl.
Give it a try.
It can't hurt.
Yeah,
set yourself some goals.
Think positive and a crack
on Derby at training.
So from,
from accomplishing your ultimate goal,
beating Klitschko,
becoming the heavyweight champion
and then falling into this deep funk,
do you think you had to go through
all this to come back again?
I think so,
yeah.
I believe I was being tested
to see what type of motto.
Awesome.
What type of character I out.
And you know,
even before the depression
I didn't appreciate things,
nothing,
nothing was value to me.
So even swimming,
cad work,
Todd fall,
if I'd worked hard and saved up for a car,
just say for five minutes,
say blk but then I won't want anymore.
It was piece of shit.
So I know if it mattered to me,
I didn't value anything,
anything that I had and I've worked hard
for and everyone knows like what I have
is blood money because I pay for him
in face and their body gets punched to
pieces for what I have.
So you'd think I'd appreciate
things more than an x mumble.
I didn't appreciate nothing.
I didn't appreciate anything,
anything a,
our daughter achieved
even world championships.
Anything I thought is that it
does this whole your whole life.
So I believe I was taught,
I was popped down this road and I had
to suffer all these things so I could
understand one hour things.
God.
Like today I'm up here that I'm
breathe in fresh air and the,
um,
I'm sat here in a mental,
mentally stable way of thinking.
I'm happy that I can go out and
enjoy your dinner and just be normal,
whatever that is.
That's what I'm up before.
I'm one of the most,
probably the most unique
paypal's you'll ever meet.
I'm not.
I'm orientated by material things and
all that sort of stuff means nothing to
me.
I don't even care about glory and honor.
I don't care about legacies.
I don't care about winning titles or or,
or metals doesn't matter.
But when I set my mind to doing something,
I'll do it.
And every single time I've ever sent
me mind to anything I've done it.
Even you'll thinkable things
of a set your mind to,
I've done it.
I don't care about one in
what Deontay wilder has,
it needs positional ever.
I only want to beat him in a fight.
Does it?
You only want to beat him
because it's so difficult.
Not just that,
because that's what I want to do.
Well,
what sets your soul set me goal?
Beaten.
Deontay wilder.
So do you think that that's the,
your future is just setting goals and
constantly trying to achieve those goals?
I think.
I think I've got a bigger
purpose now than boxing.
Boxing is a sport and some ankle.
I've made a living now for a long time,
but I think there's a bigger
picture bigger than any,
any women,
any titles bigger than when in any,
any fights,
any number of fights.
I think my calling card in life
has to spread the word on this.
This disease are silent killer.
I killed her.
That's so far Oceanus that you can't
see it or feel it from the outside.
You could be suffering right now,
but I won't be able to see it
because I can't see into your mind.
It's just so unusual that
someone has that solution,
that hard work,
dedication and setting goals is what
lifted you out of the depression and made
you appreciate life and
made you appreciate all the,
all the aspects of it.
Yup.
I appreciate everything.
You know,
spending time with my family.
I took it for granted before for
I spend nine when Tom went family.
Anytime a warm,
I couldn't put into words
what I went through.
Well,
let me just say,
I wouldn't wish what I went
through on my worst enemy.
Not that I have any enemies,
but if I did,
I wouldn't wish on a soul
because I know art is,
and I know unless a person,
maybe not,
I've got through or maybe
not a man without faith may
woulda took his own life.
Now that you have gotten through,
do you feel like you have the solution
now to navigate the rest of your life?
Yeah.
I now know the secret for me and
everybody's will be different.
But if I train every day
and I'm staying in shape,
then I'll be happy forever.
The time I stopped training the Tamar
balloon back up again to tell him it all
goes wrong again.
And I know that if you know something
in your life and you don't do it,
and that's what I know.
It's like a diabetic.
If he goes and eats a lot of sugar,
he knows he's going to make
him out so we don't do it.
So as long as I always
stay by them guidelines,
I know I'm going to be all right.
Not Sell Shit.
Right.
He wrote
so as long as well that's
the other thing too,
right?
The alcohol and the drugs
exacerbate any sort of bad
state that you have because
you're going to feel like shit.
Yeah.
I'm not tee total.
Right.
I've had a drink since I've been back.
I Bet I've been out
with a large our drinks,
whatever.
Um,
but your goals are still set and strong.
Yeah.
But really what it is.
So from now on,
you just have to continue
any set goals in your life,
set goals,
whatever those goals might be.
They don't have to be massive goals,
but they can be anything really.
Anything that I want to do or I want
to achieve or I want to go someplace or
whatever,
and I worked towards it
and set myself a goal.
It's almost like a
little treat or whatever.
It's fascinating because no
one's ever really connected that.
I mean,
people,
people have made that connection in terms
of like when they study happy people,
one of the things they
find about happy people's,
the goal oriented people,
they set goals to accomplish those people.
But nobody's ever really set that as
a remedy for depression and for mental
health issues,
setting goals,
achieving those goals.
That's the key to keep it going.
I believe that's the case.
Yeah.
After doing quite a lot of research on,
on myself and experiencing it and it
works for me and I find it works for a lot
of people I speak to who's
got the same problems.
I get messages from all all over the world
from different types of sports people
and different types of people asking
for information and help on how I,
I got free mine and what
I did and I'm happy to,
I'm up here to help.
So if there's anybody out there
who's struggling in silence,
which a lot of people are turned,
I'm always there to help if I can.
Well,
it's such an impressive and inspiring
message because you're doing it without
medication.
You're doing it just
through positive thinking,
through goal setting and
through healthy living.
That's right.
And I believe it's the best,
best way to live anyway.
That's the way to live is fit and healthy.
When you're out of shape
and you feel unfit.
And you feel terrible and nothing's
going to go right for you.
But if you feel fit,
you feel good.
It's almost natural to feel depressed
if your body is literally depressed.
If every time I go to the gym
and do a little bit of training,
whether it be a lot more metal,
I always go out of a shower
and I think I feel great.
Now training sets off an
endorphin and you blow it.
It makes you happy.
Contentment is a word we're looking for.
Contentment doesn't come free.
Material stuff,
jobs,
positions,
fame,
glory,
money,
anything.
Content.
You'll never find a temp
and while you're chasing,
and that's all stuff,
my message would be,
look around yourself and be
thankful for what you do have today.
Don't look for what you don't have.
You know,
you gotta be happy.
Be happy with who you are.
And why is my mom said,
you've got to know yourself
before you can know anybody else.
She told me yourself trying
to understand yourself.
Think what makes you happy and
do that and what makes you sad.
Don't do it.
It's very simple.
Rarely.
If so,
it makes me sad now,
then I'm not going to do any more teeth.
I want my life.
I don't want to.
And if you know somebody can lead you
down the wrong way and a wrong path in
life,
don't do it.
Simple,
very simple.
Say Self,
small time goals.
Longtime goals achieved them and move on.
Now how long did it take
you for you lose the weight?
I started training in November,
2017 400 pounds.
Yeah,
Ron.
I got down to 275 pounds
in my first fight.
Buck in June
and by August and the second fight buck,
I was 258 pounds.
I don't know if I've maintained that
weight to 62 58 that's your ideal weight.
Yeah.
From there to now.
So,
um,
what did you do
differently with your diet?
Like what did you
I was eating a lot and drinking a lot.
I just stopped all that sort of stuff.
Like my weight wasn't bought
on fro being a normal person.
He normally,
my weight was put on through
excessive drinking of lager,
does like 500 calories in one pint of
beer and I'd go out and drink a minimum of
18 of those beers,
follow by whiskey or vodka,
everything else.
Then I'd stop off on the
way home and our pizzas,
Kabobs,
chocolates,
it was excessive living.
If he put your body through torture,
you can't expect to feel great.
Right?
So what I did was society in Alfie,
not drinking
and that was it earlier.
I just trained on a daily basis
for a long period of time and at,
at sensible and clean you off to court.
Every Vinno bought if you want
faster results and then you do it.
Now you said you change
your training as well.
What did you change up
before?
I was doing a lot of 'em
along marooning and along boxing works
like 1215 rounds on the bug pad work,
all that sort of stuff.
Where in while I was
trying to lose the weight,
I was doing more short explosive stuff.
Like I was doing short,
faster on such as fast
as I could go basically.
Um,
I would do more interval
training and stuff like that.
Mainly it was a focusing on diet though.
Diet's the most important thing for
any anybody trying to lose weight.
You could train like a
Trojan warrior but not eight.
Correct.
And you go three steps forward and two
and a half buck and you find yourself
after six months,
a little bit less than yours,
but he stay in the same
position because with the Diet,
not that I'm a dietician,
but I know,
I know it works with losing weight
heavy because he all the way through me
Korean upon a lot of weight,
I lost a hundred hundred,
just over a hundred pounds
for the Klitschko fight.
The first time round
I lost over on Andre and
2527th impound before that.
Again,
so what I do to lose weight
as they go on a no carb diet,
so it will be totally Keto ketosis diet.
I put my body into Quito
shock and they say,
you should stay.
If you do need Kito Diet,
you should only do it for 11 days.
I do it for six to eight weeks.
Who said you should only do
it for 11 days are already somewhere.
Yeah,
my nutritionist.
Yeah.
He said,
no.
you can only do this diet for 11 days.
Has that have already been on it?
Six weeks.
Don't worry about it.
That's ridiculous.
Yeah,
do it.
I know guys who've done it for years now.
He goes,
it's a healthy way of living.
It prevents diabetes and all
these types of things as well.
There's definitely some benefits to it,
but there's concerns that for athletic
performance that you should have higher
carbohydrates.
True,
but at this time I was just focusing
on losing weight and the Keto Diet done
correct
is okay,
but I was doing it dirty.
How are we doing it?
How is Ivan for double parties
with cheese and mayonnaise?
Is that bad full of fighting
grace and it can't be
good for your arteries?
Kind of wow,
this is a loan.
I was often tunnels of meat,
fried,
fried with cheese,
mayonnaise,
bacon,
eggs,
sausage,
whatever.
Sounds good.
My ideal diet,
basically I was thinking,
this can't be a die.
I'm not going to lose weight.
I miss and you lost weight.
I lost the weight.
I lost it all.
Yeah.
You'd be stunned at what is
actually healthy and what's not.
Yeah.
I suppose you can't go
wrong if he cooking meat,
Walton to meet whatever they put in
in the beat for whatever it is you're
eating.
Processed foods are the ones that got
all the additives and all that stuff.
Processed foods and sugar
and bread and carbohydrates,
especially refined carbohydrates.
My life is,
I don't avoid Futz Futz my friend.
Basically,
if I look at food,
someone's on a diet,
they look at the fat content in something.
I don't look into sugar,
right,
because the thought I can burn fat off,
but sugar will go into it stores
in the body and it stays in longer.
Nit eventually turns to fat.
Did you change anything in terms of your
strength and conditioning work or your
boxing work?
Like did you,
did you hire a new boxing trainer?
Yes.
I've not got the same
trainer as I did up be fall.
And why did,
why did you switch things up?
Because it was stale in the gym.
I didn't have no motivation,
no more pain.
I have done the same thing for years
and I didn't have any more
motivation in the gym.
I that have a new new team and
I knew this going into this,
um,
[inaudible] come back
till I wanted a new team.
I wanted to start fresh.
Give me self some goals.
Give me self.
So a new team,
more positivity is that of
doing the same stuff day in,
day out,
switch off the train.
I did choice or trainer was very,
very controversial as well.
Who did you go when I went
with an unknown trainer.
Hey was 24 years old.
Who'd never trained anybody.
Why'd you do that?
Because I'll tell you the story.
He was helping out Billy Joe Saunders
where was over Emar Bay as fan of that guy
like yeah,
I love that guy too.
And he was helping out Billy Joe and he
was an amateur boxer before Ben in about
12 fights and he ate Billy Joe.
He's helping Billy Joel for a few years
and went over to [inaudible] was out in
a bar.
I was training as time during the 17 I
had two weeks training with Billy Joe
over in Spain.
He said,
well you come out and
keep me company in Spain.
I said,
yeah,
of course.
And well Mar Bay,
let's go.
I never had any intentions of training.
I went to over there for a
good drink up and a party.
So gets out that um,
we're all in the coffee shop on the,
on the part of the noose
and these two stoners,
we're walking past in Bikini's,
I mean 10 out or 10 each.
And I said to Ben Davison,
I said,
if you go and get me their numbers,
Ben,
I said,
you can be my boxing trainer.
He went,
what?
I said,
you heard me correct the first time.
So off he went.
After these two,
two good looking girls,
20 minutes goes by,
he comes back,
no number.
I said,
right.
clearly you're not the mom for me.
I said,
because the trainer I need I top minerals.
and if he can't get a woman's number,
I said,
well,
you're not clearly can't win fights.
Kenya.
Simple.
Hey Ma.
Well,
I'll show ya off all in
the mood to misstate.
It comes by that as a
number bang straight over.
I said excellent motivation.
You hired,
you hired him because he
got hot girls phone numbers.
Yup.
Hmm.
I hired him for that reason.
Not just the hot girls phone numbers.
That wasn't the case.
It was the case that he was willing to
put himself on the line to prove to me
that he could do something
that takes minerals.
And if you don't have any confidence
then you can't go over to somebody who's
really good looking and say,
oh,
on my name's Ben.
And that might make once your number,
is that possible?
Like he wouldn't have got the number and
if he didn't have any confidence and he
didn't have any gumption to him,
wouldn't have got our number.
So I knew he was a good choice because
he was young and fresh and hit a point to
prove and he wanted to do something
with his life and I give him that
opportunity and it was the
best decision I ever made.
Now what about what he knows about boxing?
Obviously that played a factor.
If he's just some random smell who
is good at getting girls numbers?
No,
it wouldn't be the train
if it was just that way.
The for this,
he was taking me on the Parkinson's stuff
in between Billy Joe sessions and we
jelled straight away.
Me And Ben think alike.
Sometimes you meet people in your life
and you're very similar in personalities
and we're like the same things.
We like to do the same thing.
It's got the same type of personality.
We've just jelled automatically.
Our Gel leaving before I said this
about the number of the girls,
I already knew that I was
going to make Ben Mie trainer.
It got a very keen eye for
boxing and what he does is,
is very,
it doesn't look like he knows a
lot about boxing by looking at,
it just looks like a young
blood could look in fella,
but when you sit down
and analyze the fighters,
a studies boxing day and night,
we'll be out watching movies
after the train bends in his room,
watching Deontay wilder,
watching the fights,
watching this and watching.
He studies the game and he's always coming
up with different game plans and how
to beat this personnel
to beat that person.
Very,
very up here.
He's very knowledgeable.
Your mother and I said before
even made him my coach.
I said within five years you're going
to be one of the lead in boxing trainers
in the world
and now he's got his chance
and if I beat Deontay Wilder,
Ben Davis and a win ring
magazine trainer of the year 2018
now,
how much different is your training
with him then with your last year?
It's different pay
towards the top trainer.
He got me to be world
heavyweight champion,
but like I said,
we never had no more
motivation in the gym.
It was stale.
There was no,
there was no vibe in the gym.
It was just like work again,
I didn't want to be there.
How to tie and training camp a few times
I've walked out at the gym every time
because I didn't want to be in the gym.
I didn't have no motivation to be there.
So the most,
the main thing is boxing is
boxing name rocket science.
You can only do a few things.
I think the most important
things in boxing is road work,
pad work,
inspiring everything else,
not interested.
My favorite thing to do is spa and I
think what better to do than practice what
you do with another person
fighting other men and that's me.
That's me,
a her finger and I've often inspired
hundreds arounds for fights to get fit and
lose weight.
James Tony used to do that too.
He used to power hundreds AANDRA's rounds
to get self fit and that's what I've
done it as well.
It gives me a favorite thing,
but now we do a lot of
strong conditioning work.
We do a lot of weights and stuff.
I figured out over here being around
like American fighters and stuff,
especially in the boxes,
they don't have that like that that can
that term program of weights and stuff.
It's more like maybe lightweights,
loader repetitions as it's
often I'm being heavyweight.
I lift heavy weight,
very heavy weights and dead lifting,
very heavy weights and bench and heavy
weights and using my body weight and in a
lot of stuff.
So I believe it's very,
very key factor in being a big strong man.
So he's responsible for that as well.
No,
I have another guy who does that.
You have another guy that's
strength conditioning one.
Yeah.
One of the things about a boxing trainer
is knowing when to pull you back,
knowing when you're peaking.
And that mostly comes
from long term success.
Working with many,
many fighters.
That's gotta be one of the biggest
chances you take with a young guy.
It is pulled.
I put him to the test many,
many times and he does.
He can say it sometimes
being a successful trainer,
doing successful things and make
it champions and then you go work.
We're not trained.
You think you don't know nothing.
Tough.
Smart.
I've worked a few trainers and fault.
I'm not going to go into any names
cause that'd be disrespectful,
but that knows when I'm feeling good.
My style is all about feelgood factor.
And if I failed,
good,
I'll fight.
Excellent.
And if I'm not failing on onto the web,
then I'll fail.
I'll,
I'll fight rubbish.
Do you know when,
like when you show up at the gym
and you're feeling like shit,
do you know when to back out of there?
You know,
often have went to the gym not wanting
to be in the gym and felt like shit,
but they're not the best training
session in middle life does happen many,
many times until you actually
work it out and get into the,
into the groove.
I don't think you can really know what
you're going to feel like until you start
training because if he went
on how he felt the falls,
the gym sometimes then you
won't be in the gym at all.
But I do believe what you said is very
correct and it's the most important thing
that anybody's ever talked about to me.
And I'm glad that you brought it up
because not a lot of people have that
ability to know when to
pull your five to buck.
And NOFX is enough.
A lot of people think because it's
a bigger fight than your last one.
You've got to try and double his art
training harder than you've ever trained
before.
No.
He run in forever.
You left him heavier?
No,
because I already trained hard,
so I don't need to train it
now to where some people think,
right,
this is wild to fight.
We need to be fitter than ever.
We need to run up a mountain carrying
a backpack on my back and pull three
bullet there and wrestle two bears,
but it's not the case on Ben knows
that's not the case is very cautious.
I've mentioned it to him many,
many times about overtraining,
overtraining,
overtraining.
How many times do you see
fighters leave all in the gym?
Quite a bit.
I don't want to leave this in the gym.
I want to leave it in
the ring on the night.
I'd rather be a little bit on fit,
a lot on fit rather than
it as an a tiny bit.
Overtrained I've been overtrained
and it's like being on the water.
You've got to go snap.
You can't put things together.
You want to,
you can,
you can see it coming,
but you can't do nothing about it.
It's worse than unfit.
Yeah,
because you're,
you're compromised.
I've been overtrained before and I've
been totally unfit fat as anything.
I'd rather be unfair 10 times a day.
Then overtrained once cannot do nothing
when you're overtrained but at least
when you were on fit,
you lose your breath.
But you read your cover when you
arrest and you get back at it again.
But overtrain you just one page,
you can't do nothing.
You never get out of the month.
No.
Now you have a strength
and conditioning coach.
And how often do you do that?
We do that five days a week.
You do?
Wow.
That's quite a bit.
Are you running?
Yeah,
we were on,
we run on three times a week.
So you're running three times a week.
Strength and conditioning
five times a week.
And on top of that,
all your boxing work?
Yeah,
we box six days a week.
Wow.
That's a lot of work.
Yep.
Now you're,
you're doing dead lifts and bench press.
And I mean,
how is this a guy that's worked
with other boxers before?
I've worked with this guy for three years.
Um,
when I first started working with him,
he worked with boxers before yet a lot
of local boxes and I'm British boxers,
but he never worked with a heavyweight
weight before and he didn't know what he
was doing because everyone
makes the same mistake.
They're only humans will train
a heavyweight labeled train,
the lightweight,
they're not boxing trainers
try for conditioning trainers.
So he was trying to make it in the
beginning and he was trying to make me do
something that attendance stone,
145 pound guy was doing,
it's not possible.
It's a different world,
but only through experience
did he realize what,
what,
what we need to do and
what we don't need to do.
And now he's like,
it's perfect.
I wouldn't change him for the world and
I don't know what I'd do if I didn't
have him because I'd have to go,
um,
go from wall.
That same learning process again,
and it's not just heavyweights is
heavyweight boxing because I had,
this guy is Mr Olympia guy and he
used to train some massive guys,
350 pounds,
solid muscle,
but he didn't know anything about boxing.
And you box in his performance sport.
And no matter if you look
like an Adonis but you,
you can't do five rounds is pointless.
I'd rather look fat to
mail to do 12 rounds.
Oh,
he had two more like an Adonis
and be fucked off to five.
No doubt.
I've knocked out plenty
of six bucks in my day.
Don't worry about that.
But um,
I'm still waiting to be
knocked out as a fat pig.
Uh,
training for Deontay wilder.
What have you done
different?
To be honest,
we haven't done anything different.
Um,
is he the tall?
As long as guy verified,
I think [inaudible] has same,
same size.
I think glitch come.
I've had longer arms maybe or maybe not,
I don't know.
But he's up there anyway.
If he is an ease is the second
tallest I've ever fault.
But every tall guy I've ever
faced to tall the better for me.
I don't know why,
but I seem to be able to
move better than them.
The Taller and heavier,
my ideal opponent would be like the tall
has anything and heavy because if they
don't move as quick and the can't
turn Gordon and all on the stiff.
Well what's unusual about you
is that you're a tall guy who's,
who moves like a guy was not tall.
Yeah.
And that most tog eyes have that advantage
of long length and utilization of
that length.
They're very good at judging distance
and they have that advantage.
But what you're doing is you're moving
around a lot on top of being tall,
which you could see with Klitschko.
It was very off putting like right away.
He didn't know how to
fuck with your timing.
It was,
you know,
that's,
that's a giant advantage.
It is all my life growing up,
I used to watch all of the great American
heavyweight champions of the world.
We may be in European,
there's a stigma about European fighters.
The stiff,
the can't move.
They're just strong.
I agree.
I agree 90% of European fighters,
a stiff robots just doing a lot of
conditioning work and left a lot of heavy
weights and they're going,
they're trying to do one thing,
one to left or right and
take four or five shots back.
I didn't want to do that.
I wanted to have European conditioning
will American style the best of both
worlds.
And I believe that's what I've got.
I've got the brashness and the movement
and the speed of an American fighter,
but I've got the European
conditioning and core strength.
Best of both worlds.
Now when you think about
a guy like Deontay wilder,
who's got this wild style and
tries to knock you out with every,
with every punch,
are you doing anything different without
giving away your strategy coming this
fight?
Are you
doing anything different in terms of your
preparation or in terms of the way you
shadow box or move or train?
Not really,
no.
Um,
how can I explain this
without sounding like a clown
or trying your best?
Don't tie Wilda as a one trick pony.
I don't need to do anything
special to beat him.
I just need to be myself.
Jump Tie.
Wilds is looking for one
right hand all night.
It's a good trick though.
I said gold trick but we all know what
happens when that trek don't lumped.
Yeah,
you've lost.
You need mall.
The one punch to beat me.
You need to be able to
set you up with footwork,
spade,
faints movement and he
doesn't have any of that.
If the Great Klitschko I'd excellent
footwork and ability to set that big punch
or couldn't do it.
What chances as big
swing a golf day on it.
If I get hit by a swinging right Tom,
does it serve donkey now it's my fault.
I want it to knock me out.
If I let wild there swing one of those
wild punches from the back of the hall
and hit me and knocked me out,
then I'll say thank you very much.
You put me out of my misery.
God bless you wilder because obviously I
can't be a great fighter that I think I
am.
If I'm getting knocked
out by swinging punches,
it's just not possible.
I don't take big shots anymore.
Years ago from before pre 2013 I used
to take everything dying in the face.
We'll try and walk through
and use my sheer strength,
size and aggression.
I'd heart and determination
to get through every event.
But as I stepped up in levels and realized
that wasn't going to get me anywhere,
but a good idea in a good
punching in the face.
So I changed me style to box in a moving,
slipping and sliding.
And people have never seen me take any
big shots because I'll just ride them
below.
Muhammad Ali used to do is
take the shots on the gloves,
go with it.
Slim slide roll.
Even as powerful as George form on walls.
He was the heavy favorite going in,
knocked out Frazier and Frazier beat
early and you had great fights over 15
rounds.
It didn't help him in that fight because
he used his greatest asset against him.
And if I can use Deontay wilder,
his own power against him,
then I've warm.
He's looking for one punch.
I am not.
So there we go.
Well,
I don't believe if he
can't run that punch,
she's lost every round.
Even he's a promoter.
Lou Dibella said recently,
he said,
if he doesn't knock Tyson
down or knock him out,
I don't see how we can win.
Now,
I don't want you looking past this,
but let's just say you
beat Deontay wilder.
How do you talk?
Joshua went to a fight.
I don't because you can
take a horse to water,
but you can't make it drink it.
So what do you do after this?
I don't do nothing.
I sit back,
retire,
go up to 450 pounds
and get back on the drink area.
What do you do?
I mean,
you don't want to,
I don't want to become depressed again.
You need to go.
Don't want to,
what do you do?
I just got to keep training,
but like I say,
I only set one goal our time and I don't
care about anything else off of them.
Beat him wilder.
And after I beat the wild,
I probably am going to
be depressed to God.
No,
no,
no.
Fuck that.
Get that out of your head.
Man,
but I don't know.
You never know.
But you can stop yourself.
Look,
you've already brought yourself back.
Yeah,
I have,
but you never know what's
around the coal on the fear.
And I don't want to look past Deontay
wilder and thinking about what I'm going
to do after that.
Right.
When I won,
I beat Deontay wilder.
I want to let him fight.
Joshua.
He keeps talking about this Joshua fight.
It's the one he keeps wanting.
So I'm going to let him go fight him.
Go fight each other.
There you go.
Take one shoals,
go fight each other.
Come back in a little free is when you
find someone that you think could beat me
again.
Well,
if he beats Joshua,
that would be spectacular for a rematch,
right?
Yeah.
And if he doesn't beat Joshua,
then it's almost like
Joshua kind of has to fight.
If he doesn't be Joshua say,
yeah.
It was about a wilder than theory for,
he didn't throw any
punches against the area.
Uh,
it is what it is,
you know,
you can't please everybody.
Inboxing and the flight games
have pretty fickle game.
Everybody likes somebody and
don't like the next person.
And you know,
the way I was saying,
I saw Roy Jones say something recently,
I'm on all video.
It was,
he said,
if Jesus Christ himself wasn't liked,
what chance have I thought?
You know what?
That is so true.
Roy.
He's a smart man.
Hundred percent.
Very smart man.
Very great legendary box.
One of the greatest of
all times in my opinion.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm talking when these
people to get them in here,
you need to get him.
And he's very knowledgeable
on the boxing game.
Giant fan of that guy.
I was,
I was with a man a couple
of months ago about Russia.
He's a Russian citizen now.
Yeah.
How good must that rush pussy be?
Excellent.
So first so good.
Not that I know.
It must be so good.
He got his own,
got a passport.
But listen man,
I'm,
I'm a giant fan of yours.
It was an honor to meet you.
Have you in here.
I wish nothing but the best.
Your story's fantastic and uplifting,
and please don't go to 450 pounds.
If you win,
we'll ease.
I might go to 459 pounds of solid
muscle and become Mr Olympia.
Listen,
keep it together.
Thanks for the kind words over.
Yes,
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Take it easy.
Go.
Bless you.